after nine Seasons a CW's a flash has
finally ended its run now that the show
has crossed the Finish Line what's next
for our favorite speedsters here's the
ending of CW's The Flash explain
ingly The Flash is an extremely
fast-paced show villains and storylines
move in and out at rapid speed even
before the four-part finale event Barry
actually dies in episode 9 at the super
vibrating hand of Wally West who is
under the influence of Ramsay Russo's
toxic zombie cells luckily Barry ends up
in a woodsy afterlife area where Oliver
Queen hangs out as part of his
posthumous duties as a specter Oliver is
able to bring Barry back to life he's
even able to return to the land of the
living himself but only as long as the
Multiverse is in Peril or there's an
after party to attend perks are being
the Specter while all that is going on
keown's still discovering her powers
freezes all the water and the toxic
zombie bodies of Team flash
incapacitating them then reanimate John
diggle so he can help flash an arrow as
Spartan
episode 10 of The Flash begins with a
mystery man but soon cuts to Iris who's
still battling early term morning
sickness and his days from labor Iris
gets a text about winning the Pulitzer
but Barry who is baby-proofing the
apartment vanishes in a bolt of blue
Lightning he's transported back to the
date his mother is killed by the reverse
flash eobard Thorne adult Barry has been
here before but now he is able to spend
more time with his parents sadly this is
also the moment he has to be the one to
tell his former self not to intervene in
his mother's death earbud kills her and
is trapped in the past closing the loop
barriers Revisited throughout his life
however a Sinister Force bigger than
reverse flashes at work and it possesses
Joe through a large blue crystal it's
the negative speed force Essence forcing
Joe to fight Barry Barry uses as
Lightning Rod connection to Iris to
Center himself and separate Joe's
Consciousness from the crystal saving
both their lives the crystal disappears
meanwhile back in Central City a large
cloud of red lightning flashes in the
sky and strikes a mystery man in the
chest when he wakes he finds a
confidential police file on Eddie Thorne
who looks exactly like him
keown avoids a pesky chore of opening
doors by turning herself into mist and
waffling in underneath she speaks to her
plans and journals but the person she
really wishes she could talk to is Mark
these last few months there were so many
things I wanted to talk to you about
I guess you just didn't want to talk to
me coincidentally Mark is back except
he's actually the negative speed Force's
current vessel he berates keown causing
her to flee then attacks the rest of
Team flashing her and Barry's absence as
the latter is still Trapped In Time
speed force Nora counsels Kion on her
powers she doesn't understand them yet
but can feel the whole world at once
speed force Nora responds that it sounds
like keown understands her powers very
well Keon confronts a possessed Mark and
with a snap of her fingers reduces his
entire body save the crystal to dust the
crystal vanishes before she can grab it
so with another snap she reassembles
Mark Cecile sends it intense panic and
joy which can only mean that iris is in
labor Barry manages to return at exactly
the right time and everyone heads to the
hospital across Central City the Eddie
doppelganger goes to ccpd for answers
but his looks done everyone's speechless
as he starts recalling Eddie's memories
he realizes he is Eddie resurrected he
digs up Eddie's empty coffin to prove it
and pulls a fatal bullet out of his a
singularity Cloud opens above
what the hell
barriers pulled to 2049 previously Barry
didn't exist in 2049 having vanished on
the crisis of infinite Earth in this
episode however 2049 Barry exists and is
simply away in Space the blue crystal is
also there and has possessed Nora when
Eddie transported by the negative speed
force wanders into the museum looking
for Barry the possessed Nora tells him
Barry sold a life Eddie should have had
but Barry Zips in and takes Eddie out of
there back at Eddie's Place Barry notice
says everything is covered in tachyans
which means they're inside the negative
speed force Eddie is persuaded by all
that negativity and won't listen to
Barry's reasoning he feels his sacrifice
was wasted and goes to see Iris to see
or projects her 2023 Consciousness into
her 2049 body to save Nora from
possession with little trouble she
forces a temporal body of the negative
speed force out of Nora's physical form
she accepts a superhero name virtue but
the crystal disappears once again
meanwhile Iris tells Eddie that Barry
was always between them that her love
for Barry was there even when she
wouldn't recognize it and that founding
their abilities the life she was meant
for infuriated Eddie goes back into the
negative speed force and accepts the
crystal becoming its new Avatar
this is not the first time the flashes
feature the negative speed force so
while it's a fitting antagonist for the
end of the series it portends in an
ending cycle that hardly indicates
closure the first few parts of a new
world follow that formula as each
episode features a new member of Team
flash being possessed and saved by
another member it's essential that Barry
finds a way to break that pattern
reunions closes a loop on Barry's pass
fulfilling the destiny revealed all the
way back in season one he's fighting
reverse flash when his mother is killed
and he dissuades his other flash cell
from intervening in order for the show
to end it needs the closest Loop of
conflict between the positive and
negative forces surrounding Central City
as well the other major character
development over the first few parts of
a new world involves keown she has
rapidly accessed powers above and beyond
anything she ever thought was possible
and certainly beyond anything her role
to egos have done before her recognizing
these changes and admitting to being a
goddess implies huge changes ahead Keon
herself rarely accepts that she will
have to leave Central City for good she
can't just help these few people in this
one place she must be everywhere for
everyone and everything the more I
embrace who I truly am
the more I see the natural Order of
Things
episode 4 has lots of ground to cover so
the show wastes no time in bringing back
some dearly departed foes zoom and
Godspeed appear and nearly come to blows
when eobard Thorne comes downstairs to
snarkily put them in their place savitar
arrives too and Eddie calling himself
cobalt blue introduces himself sengi
brought them all here to defeat team
flash together that doesn't quite happen
in fact the battle ends quickly with
Nora tricking savitar virtue mind
zapping godspeed Allegra unleashing
ultraviolet energy under Well's Thorn
and Keo knocking out Zoom with his own
lightning Eddie meanwhile gets redeemed
just in time for Barry to return to the
hospital as iris is ready to deliver
their baby the second half of the
episode is all celebration and goodbyes
with people across several different
timelines and multiverses there to see
the new baby even Harrison arrives to
tell the goddess Keon that she must
prepare to ascend Barry closes things
out by sending lightning to three future
speedsters
titled A New World Part 4 finale the
last episode Embraces several themes one
is allowing positive and negative forces
to exist in concert instead of clashing
this idea carries into society at large
where opposing viewpoints frequently
lead to violence the show is certain
disagreements are inevitable But
ultimately we are all trying to improve
things for ourselves and our loved ones
thus in and of itself is a goal everyone
can recognize the flash also focuses on
family as Nora's birth is a through line
of all four episodes of a new world as
Barry battles across time it's his love
and relationships are sent to him and
give him strength even the Redemption of
Eddie comes from the recognition of his
past his enjoying love and belief and
doing the right thing allows him to die
honorably farewells also come into play
for the show and for Keon who is taking
her place in the ether as protector of
the natural world she tells the team
that she is also abandoning her mortal
body as well in her place stands Caitlyn
who died unnaturally and therefore
according to Keon deserves her own
second chance and Second Chances have
always been a sensual theme in the Flash
Flash
in the denumar of The Flash finale Eddie
has drained of Power by Jay Garrick's
flash in the middle of jitters Eddie
recharges himself with his Fallen Legion
and enters a negative speed force to
amplify his speed even more as this was
how earbud himself once died it seems
Eddie is doomed too he only tells Barry
that she can send him to comfort Eddie
but to what end if Barry wants to save
Eddie who won't sacrifice himself for
Barry and Keon tells him he must change
his perceptions Barry has always known
balance to come with Strife but Keanu
Pines that it's about coexistence not in
Conflict but in mutual trust Barry finds
this impossible because even if he
refuses to fight his enemies continue to
come after him she tells him then you
need to believe in the impossible
because it's the only way to create a
better world Barry repeats that message
to infinora saying the lightning chose
him but now he is choosing to share that
gift with others he sends his lightning
to Future speedsters hoping to grow a
better world and break the cycles
in the negative speed force of Barry for
the final time Eddie lashes against him
with blow after blow letting his Fury
overtake him even starts to sound like
eobard continuing the cycle that has
played out time and time again Barry
picks up on this and he tells Eddie what
a good man he is and how he is becoming
the very person he would sacrifice
himself to defeat he tells Eddie that he
has a negative speed force as Avatar now
and he doesn't have to give in to the
hated bills around him he can fight it
earbud Thorne lived and died in hate but
Eddie is known love as he says this
Eddie is flooded with memories of his
previous life his happiness and finally
how Iris cried over him as he died his
final words expressed how he had always
wanted to be her hero present day Eddie
is moved by these memories so he pulls a
crystal from his chest and smashes It On
The Ground although Eddie will always be
part of the negative speed force he vows
to work with Barry instead of against
him for the good of the world
in season three of The Flash Iris tells
Barry wherever you go you'll always be
Barry and I'll always be Iris and we
always find each other those words are
remembered again as the couple celebrate
their birth of their first child Nora
now a happy Trio they look forward to
many more years together which seems
almost guaranteed in 2049 the two are
still setting up Sparks when graying
Iris gets to talk with 2023 Barry their
love is palpable and everlasting Iris of
course has won one Pulitzer and will go
on to win at least one more or Barry
chooses to share some of his flash
Powers with new Heroes of course that
doesn't mean he's going to stop fighting
crime himself as we learn in part 3 in
the future The Flash is sometimes needed
in space while on Earth he and Eddie
tried to work together to maintain the
natural order furthermore even though
Barry says watching their daughter Nora
hold their infant self is trippy even
for us Nora assures them that her little
brother Bart's birth will be even more
eventful
Joe can barely hold back tears as he
Marvels at how much Iris has grown she's
a mother herself now and he feels
amazing about how lucky he is to have
lived his life riding that high he
finally proposes to Cecile praising her
accomplishments and I know that wherever
our dreams may take us
we will always keep loving each other
this reinforces what Chuck tells her in
part three when she worries at her long
absence from Joe in 2049 must mean
something goes wrong Chuck meanwhile is
attacked by reverse flash string puff
for the finale he's saved by Allegra but
weirdly came out of the attack and skate
because of the black hole energy he
absorbs during his experiment in the
season 6 premiere he's now a
Consciousness honed universally
neutralized Kur anomaly or chunk and in
2049 he and Allegra are long married but
still hot and heavy for each other the
time traveling Harrison Wells has words
of advice for Keon he tells her that
time traveling isn't what matters for
people like them what matters is keeping
pieces of your loved ones with you
wherever and whenever you go Keon takes
us to heart and while Marcus sad to see
her go he's grateful she never gave up
on him he's also surprised and happy to
see Caitlyn back but Caitlyn for her
part is eager to get back to work
talking with Entertainment Weekly Grant
Gustin spoke about his own life changes
during the latter seasons of The Flash
and his desire to see Barry go through
similar new experiences he felt that he
and Barry went through similar ups and
downs across the years in similar stages
of their lives so the timing felt
natural to him Arrow star Stephen Amell
also spoke with ew about how the flash
finale means an end to the arrowverse as
well and how happy he is that the flash
is a show to see it out furthermore he
talked about his favorite scenes with
Grant as Oliver and Barry one of his
favorites was his last appearance on the
show in the pilot when Oliver gives
Barry his superhero name saving people
Flash
one of his other favorite scenes however
involved a simple drink at a bar between
Barry and Oliver he said season 9
showrunner Eric Wallace wrote this
beautiful scene of the two of us sitting
there having a beer if you go back and
you really pay close attention to the
dialogue it's pretty much Verbatim what
I said to him in the pilot of the flash
that was a really neat full circle
moment with that the flash closes yet
another loop